this video is sponsored by the book
summary app blankist use the link in the
description to receive one free week and
25 off a premium membership
we've all experienced nostalgia before
that feeling of sentimentality longing
or affection for our past it is a
poignant experience that intimates the
passing of time and reminds us of who we
once were but will never be again
when looking back sometimes even just a
year it can often feel like we are
observing a person and life that is
completely different a stranger
experiencing an almost unrecognizable
life and sense of self but of course
this person was us and of course we are
also us right now
but then
who are we what makes us who we are what
does our present self have in common
with our past self of 10 years ago what
will it have in common with our future
self in 10 more years is there anything
that truly persists through it all that
makes and keeps us who we are what is it
if there is
for starters when trying to pin down
what makes us who we are we might
consider our body but in truth most of
us don't really find our body to be the
primary source of our sense of self for
example if you lost all your limbs it is
fair to assume that you would still feel
and claim to be you even taken to the
extreme if somehow you lost your whole
body but could still live and experience
the world from within your head carried
around in a jar or placed on some sort
of android although a strange and
different life you would likely still
feel and claim that you are you
not only that but regardless of what you
claim essentially all the cells that
comprise your body are replaced anew
every 10 years or so so if you identify
yourself with the consistency of your
body your body is never really
physically the same anyway
and of course throughout your life your
body's appearance changes completely as
well your eight-year-old self looks
essentially nothing like your 30 year
old self but you almost certainly would
never claim that one is more or less you
and of course the circumstances of your
life essentially change completely as
well even if you live in the same place
the same place changes all the time and
so there is nothing really outside of
your body that can be identified with
either
instead of the body or our circumstances
most of us identify primarily with our
brain
but what part of the brain is us
the brain is an immensely complex organ
with tons of components and functions
and most of us wouldn't identify with
much of it we likely don't feel like we
are the parts of the brain involved with
automatic unconscious functions and
responses the regulation and adjustment
of the breath and heart and balance and
all the other things that happen beneath
our direct control and awareness
we might say then that we are the parts
of our brain related to our tastes and
preferences
but what if this part of your brain was
altered would you no longer be you if
yes doesn't this happen all the time
throughout life in general are we not
constantly changing our tastes and
preferences across our lifetime
what about if the parts of our brain
affecting how we talk and act changed
what if we lost or gained sets of skills
again don't these things occur all
throughout life as well
how about the way in which we respond to
things our character and temperament and
humor and so on again arguably this
changes continually as well
imagine what you liked what you were
good at what you cared about how you
talked and how your temperament was 15
years ago are these things at all
similar in any real substantial way to
you now
probably no more than a distant friend
at best
and so if we as a central and consistent
thing are not our bodies not our brains
unconscious functions not our tastes and
preferences not our technical capacities
and not our character who or what are we
perhaps the most fundamental thing that
makes us feel like the same person
across our lifetime is our memory this
seems to be the most difficult thing to
imagine we would still be ourselves if
we lost it but what does that mean for
people who have extreme long-term memory
loss like certain individuals with
alzheimer's disease are they no longer
themselves do they no longer have a self
if so who are they are they somehow
nobody if so who is it that we are
interacting with when we interact with
them
perhaps they are nobody in the way we
typically think of somebody but perhaps
so are you
in truth for all of us if we look into
our body and mind to try to find
precisely and concretely who or what we
are that central persistent something
that makes us we find this strange
nobodiness
in the words of fernando passoa
i've changed at every moment i always
feel like a stranger i've never seen or
found myself i am my own landscape i
watch myself journey various mobile and
alone here where i am i can't feel
myself that's why i read as a stranger
my being as if it were pages not knowing
what will come and forgetting what is
past
rereading i wonder
was that me
from a neuroscientific understanding
this notion of there not being a defined
self is validated by the fact that there
is no part of the brain where everything
comes together for an ego or self to
form or for a sort of center stage where
thoughts are displayed perceived and
evaluated consciousness is a cascade of
neurophysiology and everything is
distributed everywhere said modern
neuroscientist and philosopher sam
harris
the self appears merely to be a
particular kind of illusion
it is not that we don't have a self but
that the self is just not how it feels
or appears to us as opposed to a
singular central unitary thing that is
carried forward from each moment to the
next it is a process an emergent
phenomenon of a non-central inconsistent
progression and unfolding of everything
we knowingly and unknowingly interact
with a seeming feedback loop takes place
between the world our body and our mind
and out of which the experience of self
emerges
in other words the self is merely an
experience of a process and as long as
we persist through time there is nothing
to be found that is constant that
persists through us
it is a common thing to say and believe
that it is important to be yourself in
life when we aren't it can feel ashaming
and dissatisfying when we notice others
aren't we can feel a discomfort distrust
or an unappealing nature to their
company being ourself is in fact an
important and worthy goal if not perhaps
one of the worthiest goals in human
existence
but the problem is if the self is an
illusion
how do we be it
perhaps being yourself doesn't require
knowing yourself in any ultimate sense
perhaps it isn't even about being who
you think you are it isn't a matter of
being consistent or doing what you or
other people expect you to do based on
what you've done or who you've been
rather it is doing and being what you
feel is an honest embodiment of what you
think and want right now
a foolish consistency is the hobgoblin
of little minds adored by little
statesmen and philosophers and divines
with consistency a great soul has simply
nothing to do he may as well concern
himself with his shadow on the wall
speak what you think now in hard words
and tomorrow speak what tomorrow thinks
in hard words again though it contradict
everything you said today
ah so you shall be sure to be
misunderstood
to be great is to be misunderstood
wrote ralph waldo emerson
being who you are is being who you
become and then being who you become
and then being who you become over and
over
being yourself is a continual process of
being someone else
in the end there is nothing defined or
be but a process of finding and being
[Music]
these ideas and questions echo
throughout human history across the
globe from modern neuroscience back to
the buddha advaita vendanta of hinduism
ancient greek philosophers like
heraclitus and plato and everywhere and
everyone in between for as long as
people have known they are someone we
have struggled to pin down who that
someone is
of course because of the ambiguous and
unbreachable nature of selfhood all of
this is just theory and one perspective
and as the only person who will ever
experience the self and perspective that
is you you are free to think of yourself
in any way you'd like
ultimately possessing this experience of
self is perhaps the most strange
disorienting and beautiful thing unique
to the human experience to feel like and
be aware of a self compels us to try to
define it it implicates attachment to it
and the things it attaches to it
provides us with a front row seat to the
rising and falling action of the strange
show of the universe that ultimately
ends with a scene that kills its
audience
it is part tragic play and part magic
show that strikes divinity into even the
most secular of individuals we are each
given this gift of selfhood an illusory
paradoxical experience of something and
nothing of experiencer and experiences
the conjunction of both a run-on
sentence always being added to with an
and
and perhaps all we can and should try to
do is make the sentence as beautiful as
we can rich with the cadence of poetry
the diversity of a complete story and
the punctuation of an exclamative
[Music]
if you're interested in further
exploring the current version of
yourself consider checking out my guided
journal designed to help you understand
and evolve the ever-changing thing that
is you
[Music]
something that's extremely fascinating
to explore is the way in which largely
disconnected cultures times in history
and disciplines of thinking have arrived
at technically similar conclusions both
about the self and many other
theoretical topics traditionally it
would be extremely time consuming to
explore something as vast as this but
this video sponsor blinkist makes it
easier than ever to engage and study
from a wide range of books in a fraction
of the time blinkist allows the average
person to engage in roughly 30 times the
amount of books in the same amount of
time by taking the best non-fiction
books pulling out the key takeaways and
forming them into 15 minute text and
audio summaries this means on blinkist
you can explore how buddhism understands
and defines the self through a title
like buddhism plain and simple by steve
hagen how neuroscientists understand the
self through the title the brain by
david eagleman and how it might be
explored in western philosophy through
meditations on first philosophy by rene
descartes all allowing you to understand
how these various disciplines and
theories overlap and explore the mind
the self and reality all in less than 45
minutes
lincus has over 5000 titles in 27
categories as well as summaries of
popular podcasts and a wide selection of
audio books meaning there's essentially
something for everyone in every form use
the link in the description and you'll
receive one free week of unlimited
access as well as twenty five percent
off a premium membership the free 7-day
trial can be canceled at any time within
the trial period
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you next
video
[Music]
you